si mais si vous aviez une bio ce serait
que j'aurais pu écrire comment j'ai
rendu riche mon avocat serait sympa déjà
non c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'en 2004 et
vous avez même pas non mr vous avez
écrit qu'on m'aime bien où j'en écris 2
plusieurs as well nous était connu et
riche
oui et ça nous était plus connue est
pauvre non et bah écoute et on attend la
prochaine
messieurs vous allez on écrit on dans
notre but on a eu un jeu ludivine merci
des plats mois en toute modestie lui
divinement belle non tout modèle selon
vous la péter papa j'ai voir si ludivine
stillman a eu deux mois quand ça nous a
pris ce nom vient à caen c'est déjà pris
lui ça lui là bas pour un rangement
discutent ce schéma doit discuter tout à
l'heure j'ai en plus j'ai pas le permis
pour le coc voiture
en france ira je pense que la semaine
prochaine dans les bagnes sera dans les
plus gros bon sens
la défense la folle histoire d'amour
comme on y va et on n'a pas de vulgarité
c'est bon non je vais rien dire
non moi j'avais déjà écrit une bio mais
en faire une loi ça pétait lerate à
l'époque quand j'étais viré de tf1
ah oui tout le temps si ben oui bah
c'est marquant quand même des marques on
vous aide directe s'est vite aussi et
donc non non non moi je ferais l'ami des
stars mais qui raconterait un peu
l'envers du décor la ville anita voilà
excusez moi vous avez bossé soudan sla
et aoued accord est mais c'est sympa oui
non mais raconter la vérité si vous
doublez raconter quelque chose d'ici
d'une star sait qu'il a plus grandes
stars ici sur ce plateau riz voulait
dire médiatiquement ou au niveau du
travail est déjà effectuée alors à ce
moment que j'avais une nouvelle fois
faire je ne comprends pas votre moi je
viens moi ça arrive en france la
dernière manche voilà je comprends pas
alors sur ce plateau c'est benji
et qu'est ce qu'il fallait dire sur le
nord parce que benji ces normes parce
que au-delà du travail qu'il a effectué
à la télé c'est toutes ces histoires
d'amour ça passionnés non non et ses
arches et médiatique benji et puis pour
être une star france marié cinq fois il
a bien cette fois gentil silvey moins
pur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sors à coude avant bonsoir quel est
votre identité
il ya des maximes pour vous servir alors
[Applaudissements]
alors le titre de votre bio ce serait
quoi d'humour et de frêche c'est
toujours un gars à l'humour humour c'est
une évidence et eau fraîche
parce que je suis frais comme un gardon
ah ouais d'accord merci et votre
connerie y est on est où c'est donc à
cet égard un jour gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais j'ai une idée du titre de votre
bureau j'ai toujours eu du pif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez ça c'était 50 nuance données non
vous n'êtes pas magnifique écrit une bio
sur vous je serai fatou il faut rendre
la bague
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors votre bio ce serait quand j'étais
comme eux non ouais
trois mille anecdotes de vie est belle
est vachement bien ouais vous savez que
vous êtes de très très belles vous non
mais je vous dis à chaque fois que vous
vous en photo je trouve l et quand je
vous vois henri je trouve encore plus
belle non mais c'est vrai ça c'est un
prince à vous assister encore un peu je
mets le croire
[Applaudissements]
alors oui bon bref en tout cas le
bouquin alors on me l'a proposé j'ai
accepté je suis dans mes adieux du pas
fait quelque chose à quoi confidences
d'un lieu du bara oui oui c'est pas mal
oui quand même
c'est quoi auto préface est tous prêts
faciles et voilà on a besoin de
géraldine line juste vous partez aussi
directement après vous ça vous va très
bien maxime amis mais on m'a dit que
c'était moins bien sur lui mais tout est
moins bien sûr merci surtout qu'il est
alors qu'elle n'est jamais sûr maxime
non mais je vous le dis je vous rappelle
que c'est un amour platonique platonique
qui vient de platon bien entendu la
compo nombre à ceux qui nous regardent
beaucoup michel platini si ça vous plaît
oui merci
alors moi mon livre ce serait allégorie
psychanalytique d'un râteau d'accord
voici déjà le titre chiant 1
le titre est très chiant trouver oui
j'en lis est mort d'accord oui oui
qu'est ce que vous avez fait là c'est
quoi cette nouvelle
c'est presque c'est pas très bon mais je
trouve que c'est magnifique
sinon il en est comment vos niveaux
vocabulaire progrès selon michel mr et
là le snack heures
[Applaudissements]
le sniper
c'est la gentille je préfère sniper
officiel d'accord on fait un petit
coucou à jean luc qui nous regardent
certainement et qui qu'ils soient pas
triste voilà c'est la vie la roue tourne
jean luc est là le lundi et le mercredi
weight rien à voir avec ça sera encore
sniper meilleurs comme par hasard comme
alors c'est quoi votre eau n'est
évidemment style pur style peur et sans
reproche cypher et sans reproche je
crois que vous êtes alors franchement
entre vous deux c'est pas qu'ils aient
plus loin
abbas et lui non non non c'est les deux
et vous kelly à moi ce serait ma vie de
blonde platine d'accord rapports avec
l'état un livre acheté un cours d'air
offert un conte dernière disait ah ouais
d'accord mais vous pourrez sauter ça
mais c'est très sympa d'être venu non
mais c'est pas fini
et
v